all right this is pretty interesting a
former president donald trump has a
new uh spokesperson his spokesperson
had been that guy jason miller but
miller stepped down last week
and the new spokesperson is a woman
named liz harrington
liz harrington used to be the
spokeswoman for the republican national
committee
she's a real bomb thrower and
harrington's big qualification appears
to be that
she supported a whole bunch of lies
about the 2020 election which trump
liked including the lie that
president biden's strong performance in
some democratic counties clearly was a
sign that there must have been some kind
of election
fraud and one of the things that we've
been talking about is
why might it be that even now so many
republican elected officials are either
standing by trump or at least not
criticizing donald trump and it seems
pretty clear that the reason is
they see him probably rightly so as
still wielding lots of power
even for their own possible re-elections
in 2022
and they don't want to burn a bridge
until they know they're not going to
need to drive over that bridge any time
soon so donald trump
announces this new total suck-up
brown-nosing
a spokeswoman says that harrington is a
fighter
apparently a fighter for completely
bogus conspiracy theories
and harrington is just off to a blazing
start she appeared on i don't even know
what this is
the real america's voice show
just the truth the truth is that the
show is all lies
and in this clip harrington says that
the january 6th
trump riots were a peaceful protest
among many other lies you'll notice also
that
the interviewer is former i guess it's
former trump lawyer or was she trump's
lawyer you know but we never really know
uh sometimes she was sometimes she
wasn't jenna ellis
she's the one that caught covid while
traveling around the country with rudy
giuliani
pushing completely bogus voter fraud
stuff so let's jump right in this is
trump's
new spokeswoman liz harrington here we
go oh absolutely
and again we've seen it there's such a
void i mean
you're not going to get it from the
biden regime because everyone knows he's
not actually running things so there's
two things here that are important
the biden regime is another phrase that
they've started using and this is of
course
part of their idea that they want to
push that the biden administration is
some kind of dictatorial
communist government controls everything
sort of administration so biden regime
is one thing we're hearing from them the
second piece is
the idea that biden isn't really running
the show
and the idea so this is actually twofold
there's a
like the big story and then the little
one the big story is
it's the biden dementia story that it's
really kamala harris or someone else
who's
running the administration but this
happens to fit perfectly
with anti-semitic stuff for republicans
as well
and what i mean by that is the concept
of a behind-the-scenes jewish puppeteer
pulling the strings of american
government that's a classic anti-semitic
trope
and so there's also sort of some
symbolism there as to why that's so
appealing to many on the right it's not
overtly anti-semitic although there were
you know these uh things floating around
about you know a lot of jews here
ron claine and janet yellen and i don't
know who at blinken i don't remember who
else
so it's it's all kind of part of this
package and it doesn't always have to be
overtly signaling
jews but the idea of like the real
people pulling the strings behind the
scenes
it's implicitly part of an anti-semitic
trope all right let's continue
and it's so important at this time in
our country i mean we have
no equal justice under the law right now
at the federal level
that's completely untrue other than if
you mean
that we have a two-tiered justice system
where the rich and the powerful
are in a different sort of class of
their own what she means is certainly
not true
i mean just look at what they're doing
with the justice department you know
they didn't look into
any of these irregularities oh no that's
not the federal government's role right
it's literally not it's literally not
the role and
these are the very same people who
constantly insist
elections are run at the state level
which is why we should be allowed
to restrict voting however we want we
shouldn't have the federal government
involved in any way and how elections
take place no voting rights act no
nothing until
all of a sudden they say well we have
six six or seven
you know bogus election fraud claims why
isn't the federal government now getting
involved
the state's role and then all of a
sudden here comes a forensic audit
uh authorized forensic audit by the way
come on
so the constitution and here comes the
corrupt justice department
i mean and we're talking about peaceful
protest
it was not a peaceful protest if if
anything was not a peaceful protest
it was the january 6 riots which now has
about 400
criminal defendants who had january 6
they opened the doors of the capitol
which is supposed to be i mean
we've both been there it's not an easy
building to get into
well that is of course not what happened
first of all
uh protesters physically breached the
door
and secondly for their own safety and to
avoid tramplings
officers had no choice but to get the
hell out of the way so
every detail is being misstated here you
know there's that many people they open
the doors and people walk through
obviously we're not condoning breaking
property
or violence oh you're not some people
just got just walked
in and now they're being kept and for
misdemeanors
in some political jail and what is
happening here what
what about the people that burned down
st john's church st john's church by the
way
uh was not burned down and that is yet
another one of the distortions and lies
here so
in all seriousness they are going to
continue trying to rewrite the story
of what happened on january 6. we can't
let him do it
st john's wasn't burned down it was not
a peaceful protest
um and uh consider how far things have
gone
that donald trump's new spokeswoman who
is the former republican national
committee spokeswoman
sounds more like q anon than she sounds
like mitt romney you know just a kind of
milk toast republican that we've come to
know
uh more more of this uh and by the way
they continue these conflicting
narratives of nothing
really happened on january 6th but if it
did
it wasn't trumpists it was people
pretending to be trumpets that also is a
narrative that continues so
for now as you see you know former rnc
spokeswoman is now trump's spokeswoman
the republican party seems at least for
now completely fine
staying completely associated with
donald trump
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15 percent off
a high quality wristwatch is the perfect
way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman